I am Nikhil SP with recent TV and today
we're talking with Roger bate who's a
resident scholar at AEI the American
Enterprise Institute he's got a PhD in
Applied Economics and he is the author
of fake the deadly world of falsified
and substandard medicines thanks Roger
for talking to us my pleasure
how widespread is the problem with
falsified or fake counterfeit
prescription drugs around the world well
it depends where you are I mean if
you're in Africa it's a significant
problem maybe 10 15 20 percent of the
supply is falsified or at least
substandard there's a gray area between
where there's an intent to deceive the
patient or just sloppy production so it
depends on the law so a substandard drug
could be something that was just made
poorly but it's not actually fraudulent
or it hasn't been adulterated that's
correct yeah and a lot of drugs lose
their potency right if that's what done
or it conveyed in the right way a lot of
drugs don't have the right active
ingredients for the right amount some of
them are just unstable so that if
they're left on the dock or in a in a
pharmacy with bad climate control which
is most of Africa then they can decay
what are the biggest drugs that get
counterfeited or sold in a in a kind of
gray market the key thing to work that
out is actually to put yourself in the
place of the counterfeiter the key thing
for them is to be able to make drugs
sell them regardless of the price to a
certain extent and be able to get away
with it I've seen fakes of pills that
cost 40 US cents in India so it's not
just the price of the drug but having
said that if you can break into the US
market faking viagra which a lot of
people want to do or faking oncology
drugs which sell for like $2,000 a
prescription you can make a lot more
money a few years ago wasn't there a
mass of lipitor scam going around the
world hundreds of thousands of pills of
lipitor were faked there were there were
recent the most recent fatal incident in
the United States that we know of is
about 149 Americans dying from fake
heparin which is a blood thinning drug
but often it's very difficult to know if
you've got a condition like leukemia oh
you've got a heart condition if you have
a heart attack
no one's likely look for the did the
drug not work you know the evidence is
usually swallowed so I would argue that
there are more cases than are generally
reported but it is a lower problem in
the u.s. what is the government's role
in
of regulating this or controlling the
flow of prescription drugs and what what
are the kind of market approaches okay
well the FDA Food and Drug
Administration does a reasonable job of
overseeing the production plants where
they can get to them and so that
regulation I think is important in and
of itself but also because it encourages
better behavior it's a kind of carrot
and stick patients can't possibly tell
the difference between a good pill and a
bad bill so it's it's important that
there's regulation there it's enforced
but of course the FDA can't have
unfettered access to production plants
in China they have to give notice now
I'm a typical guy my wife if I've oh no
she's coming home in an hour and
apartments a mess I can tidy it up in an
hour if you're given a weeks notice in a
Chinese production plant you can
probably make it look pretty good so the
FDA has a role but given how much we get
from overseas 80% of the ingredients in
our drugs come from overseas it comes
down to the companies primarily everyone
in the distribution chain has a role to
play in monitoring for problems the most
recent problem was fake Avastin which is
a cancer drug and it was found by the
distributor as new technologies
developer new markets develop are we
seeing all of the factors in the supply
chain getting better at monitoring
things so is this a problem that will go
down or is it a problem that is starting
to get out of control the data point to
it getting worse but that it could be
because we're paying more attention it's
rather the classic cases where we
finding more cases every year but that
may be because we're looking and doing a
better job of finding it but I think the
problem is probably getting worse in
richer countries and certainly in other
parts of the world as criminals become
more sophisticated it's easier to print
packaging and after all the
counterfeiter the prime job is to make
the pill and the packaging look as good
as possible what would have cost tens of
thousands of dollars in machinery can
now be done in hundreds of dollars with
printing technologies so it's easier to
fake stuff now the counterfeiters will
try and insert their products wherever
they can if you buy online you can do so
relatively safely if you go to a
credential pharmacy either accredited by
the national associations of the boards
of pharmacy or if you're looking for
really cheaper products from overseas
pharmacy check accom credentials about
50 or 60 overseas pharmacies the rest
and we're talking maybe 10,000 are
really just web sellers they're not
pharmacies and often they are going to
sell you products that may not have been
regulated and certainly and sometimes
products that are totally bill
it's when we sampled from the field it's
not what about 370 different products we
found quite a few fakes coming out of
China
we're big libertarians have reason if we
get rid of the prescription drug regime
in America so would institutions kind of
crop up that would actually start
regulating you know Good Housekeeping
seals of approval that would be much
more stringent and much more effective
than the FDA in this instance because
it's very difficult for the patient and
even the pharmacists to spot it
regulation is going to be important but
yeah the companies and the technologies
that are evolving to deal with this
problem are coming online from companies
so spectrometers handheld spectrometers
so to actually be able to spot fake soon
I would imagine within the next 5 10
years there'll be an app for an iPhone
where if you're a regular take your
lipitor you'll be able to scan the pill
itself because you'll be able to see and
I think putting the power for the
consumer will ultimately be the test and
then if a pharmacy routinely is selling
bad products it'll get sued talk a
little bit about the third man the grade
or 50s thriller set in post-war Europe
and Vienna what is the main plot point
of that story faking products be it
pharmaceuticals or currency or other is
what is often considered the second
oldest profession and Orson Welles did a
good job of demonstrating this in the
movie the Third Man where he plays a
counterfeiter he's doing the classic
trick of the counterfeiter which is to
dilute a product in this case he's
diluting penicillin to make more money
and selling it to hospitals indirectly
and sometimes directly killing kids who
have meningitis it gets across nicely
because at the time our Hollywood
actually was ahead of the curve
it was four years before a lot of the
pharmacies associations in Europe set up
specifically to deal with adulterated
diluted penicillin how did you get into
the interest in this topic well over the
last 15 years have been doing a lot of
work on malaria and HIV in 2004 when
were in Zimbabwe and we came across
people who were not responding to their
HIV medication as best as they should
have done the doctors weren't certain of
the course Zimbabwe was a mess then and
is not that much better now and the
doctors they didn't have the time to
actually do a kind of audit of where the
problems were but I think that was the
first time I witnessed fake drugs being
ingested by patients and I went back the
year later and the two patients that
I've spoken to have died so I think you
know that that was not conclusive proof
but it was the thing that sparked my
interest
and then like all policy wonks you know
you start looking at the data and
realize there isn't very good
there aren't very good data and it
started investigating from there I want
to thank Roger bate of the American
Enterprise Institute and the author of
fake the deadly world of falsified and
substandard medicines for talking with
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie thanks
you